bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 pour le 7-8 chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi une heure sur notre antenne
pour faire un point complet sur
l'actualité locale en plateau pour
débuter cette édition emmanuel à
linselles le directeur du pôle exclusion
de la croix-rouge dans le département
des yvelines
vous nous direz tout à l'heure comment
se passent vos interventions comment se
passe est les maraudes avec ces
conditions est difficile on débute ce
donc cette édition avec quelle la neige
elle tombe encore ce soir et les
températures devraient encore se
rafraîchir dans les prochaines heures
la neige qui tombe donc toujours dans
les yvelines si vous nous suivez à 18h
en direct sur tv filer les conditions de
circulation étaient difficiles dans
l'agglomération déjà aux alentours de
16h30 non pas en raison d'un sol
glissant à cause d'une circulation
importante
nos équipes ont notamment été bloqués
sur le terrain elles ont relevé
d'importants bouchons autour du
rond-point des bouviers à guyancourt
presque une heure pour parcourir entre 2
à 3 km idem pour relier saint cyr
l'école à saint quentin en yvelines près
d'une heure et sur la nationale 10 aux
alentours de 17 heures circulation
plutôt fluide et citadins de son côté
annoncé sur internet 73 km de bouchons
en ile de france c'est un peu moins que
la moyenne est la tendance est stable à
soyez toutefois prudent sur les routes
la neige qui est tombée cet après-midi
s'est transformé en flaques d'eau sur un
sol salée elle les températures froides
de la nuit pourrait compliquer les
conditions de circulation en raison du
verglas
l'alerté orange à la neige et au verglas
justement est maintenue jusqu'à 22
heures ce lundi soir privilégier les
transports en commun trafic normal sur
la ligne c du rer également sur les
lignes sncf paris montparnasse
rambouillet bonsoir donc emmanuel alain
là directeur du pôle exclusion de la
croix-rouge yvelines je vous propose un
chiffre pour débuter cette séquence - 5
c la température attendue demain dans le
département des yvelines avec cette
vague de froid qui accompagne la neige
la croix rouge est plus que jamais
mobilisé es ce que vous avez intensifier
vos maraude ses interventions auprès des
sdf absolument depuis jeudi nous avons
intensifié les maraudes aujourd'hui nous
avons
deux équipes qui fonctionne de 15 heures
à minuit en permanence et nous avons le
renfort des structures bénévoles qui
varie de deux à quatre équipes
supplémentaires de 20 heures à minuit
vous restez un plateau avec nous nous
allons juste nous rendre dans les rues
de saint quentin en yvelines johanna
soudry fait le point sur les
conséquences de ces intempéries ces
derniers jours la neige est arrivée ce
week end et lundi après-midi les flocons
sont encore tombés sur le sol saint
quentinois le département des yvelines
est placé en vigilance orange jusqu'à 22
heures
l'ensemble des routes primaires et
secondaires ont été traités sur la
communauté d'agglomération les saleuses
qu'on cumule et les sorties au total
sept pour ce week end
120 tonnes de sel ont été déversées sur
les grands axes ainsi que des petites
routes
si les transports scolaires avait été
interrompue aujourd'hui ils reprendront
demain le réseau stibus lui a déclenché
son plan neige impliquant le déplacement
de certains terminus exemple avec la
ligne 463 qui n'a pas pu accéder au
quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt outre les retards tous les bus
articulés ont été rentrés au dépôt
entraînant la suppression de quelques
courses
la neige devrait tomber jusqu'à 22h
formant une couche de 2 à 5 cm
d'épaisseur
on va tourner autour de zéro degré et
en fin de nuit on pourra descendre à
moins à moins 3 ce qui peut entraîner
quelques problèmes de glace au sol
sur le réseau secondaire demain un
épisode pluvio neigeux est attendu en
fin de matinée avant un retour dans
l'après midi
mais jeudi retour du froid avec des
températures négatives
emmanuel alors vos interventions pour la
croix rouge sont rendues plus difficiles
par les conditions météo pour les
équipes sur le terrain plus difficile
bas par les eaux des conditions de
circulation
donc en fait on a ou là une petite
stratégie c'est à dire que comme on
augmente le nombre de moyens sur le sol
terrain on essaie de répartir sur le
secteur géographique afin de d'éviter
les déplacements il se concentrer sur
des sur des zones
voilà la loi de grattage sur l'ensemble
du département aujourd'hui pour ces
différentes maraude où vous intensifier
les efforts sur certains secteurs
alors on intervient sur l'ensemble du
sur l'ensemble du département de toute
l'année les maraudes elles sont
intensifiées essentiellement sur un
public en très grande exclusion puisque
on a des capacités d'hébergement qui
sont dans les yvelines en bonne
adéquation donc suffisante
donc on a moins personnes qui sont à la
rue dont déjà ça réduit le travail par
contre on vise un public très très
exclus ont collé qui sont classés comme
vulnérable pour voir régulièrement et
qu'on voit tous les jours en période de
grand froid
vous allez régulièrement les voir avec
l'espoir qu'un jour il accepte de vous
suivre
c'est un public difficile qui ne
souhaitent pas forcément l'hébergement
mais on maintient le lien d'abord ils
sont vulnérables par soit parce que ce
sont des personnes âgées soit avec une
problématique de santé donc les déjà il
ya une surveillance nécessaire
et puis on reste un petit peu plus
longtemps oui qu on essaie d'être un
petit peu plus persuasifs pour qu'ils
aillent dans les centres on attend libre
à eux d'accès mais sa porte parfois ses
fruits on a des gens qui je vous dise
bon et aujourd'hui j'y vais et puis des
fois c'est le déclic s qui restent
plusieurs jours avec le froid qui
s'intensifie la neige qui tombe
également est ce que ça change aussi
leurs regards leurs points de vue sur
ces structures d'accueil d'hébergement
au bout d'un moment elles se disent
effectivement il faut mieux
que je rejoigne une structure est tout à
fait ça dépend des ça dépend de l'heure
de leur lieu de vie avec qui sont gardés
dans des squats relativement bien abrité
qui voilà donc c'est pas la
problématique de la neige départ n'est
pas évident par contre pour certains oui
ça c'est un site quand même un jour
naissant comment se passe justement
votre travail d'identification de ces
différents endroits dans le département
parce que vous avez mentionné ces squats
mais il faut déjà les connaître mais
trouver ça aussi ça fait partie du
travail des équipes sur place que ce
soit salariée ou bénévole
c'est le principe de la maraude alors
nous on fonctionne toute l'année donc le
genre lui dire que la connaît quand même
pas mal le le secteur et le principe de
la marotte en dehors des visites
traditionnelles de nos personnes les
plus vulnérables
c'est un petit peu des réaux hasard et
de voilà d'aller à la rencontre d'un
éventuel d'une éventuelle personne et ça
ça porte ses fruits parce que c'est
notre public cible
c'est à dire celui qui ne qui ne fait
pas le 115 que s'il sait pas comment ça
fonctionne ou parce que il est très à
l'écart de de tout système donc voilà
c'est ça la force de la barousse alors
justement euro/dollar ensuite de ses
interventions
comment vous allez organiser le travail
dans les prochains jours peut-être une
fois que les intempéries se seront
passées vous allez réduire les
interventions maintenir une certaine
vigilance alors probablement enfin là
actuellement houleux
le préfet a déclenché le niveau 2 donc
on intensifie effectivement les maraudes
et on a augmenté les capacités places
d'hébergement à ce qu'on imagine cesser
du jour au lendemain dès que le plan
grand froid est réduit vous réduisez
directement les interventions au sart
est progressive je veux dire franchement
il ya effectivement leblanc niveau 2 qui
est déclenché nous on travaille à selon
la réalité du terrain
on n'attend pas forcément le
déclenchement du niveau 2 pour
intensifier ses maraudes ou pour mettre
des places disponibles et voilà il sait
pas parce que le niveau 2 va tu vas être
stoppé et qu'il faut pas venir en aide
aux personnes qui sont voila voila on
mais on met les moyens
on a des cautions à l'aridité du besoin
quels sont ses moyens aujourd'hui qui
sont mis en place
combien de personnes interviennent sans
terrain combien de maraude alors
aujourd'hui on a donc entre 15h et 20h
on a deux équipes de maraude et à partir
de 20h on en a trois supplémentaires
donc ce qui représente une dizaine de
personnes à peu près qui est assez
suffisant parce que les centres ouvrent
à 17h et que à part ces abrutis s'était
engagé à les gens ont rejoint les
centres alors d'une maraude combien de
personnes vont réussissez à toucher à
rencontrer c'est très aléatoire
c'est très aléatoire c'est très
aléatoire parce que ça va dépendre du
secteur l'intervention ça va dépendre du
secteur d'intervention
et puis ça va dépendre voilà de la
concentration de la population un petit
peu à la rue qui s'est plus important de
ce que certains c'est clair que d'autres
une dernière question pour vous
interveniez sur le terrain il faut vous
contacté auparavant vous intervenez
selon un cercle et vous avez déjà défini
auparavant comment ça fonctionne
concrètement une intervention une
maraude alors on a en fait les on est un
système de régulation d'un régulateur
qui fait d'interface entre les services
publics
le 115 samu pompiers police qui peuvent
nous appeler en direct pour des
signalements et puis et qui fait
l'interface avec les équipes de terrain
donc c'est lui qui répartit les équipes
selon selon besoin et qui harmonise un
petit peu tout ça merci amène à lalinde
être venu nous parler donc de votre
travail de ses interventions des équipes
de la croix rouge qui se sont
intensifiées en raison du froid de la
neige vigilance orange jusqu'à la fin de
la soirée aux alentours de 22 heures
mais vous serez toujours présent au delà
vous nous l'avez dit pour s'adapter bien
évidemment aux réalités du terrain ces
intempéries comment les avez vous vécu
nous sommes allez vous poser la question
pour voir les difficultés que vous aviez
ou non rencontré balade
boule de neige
j'ai pris la voiture n'ont pas de
problème très bien très très bien pas de
panique c'est par est agréable on a
l'impression qu'on est presque dans une
station de ski
puis les enfants profitent donc voilà on
a tout annulé
et on en a profité à fond j'ai pas eu de
problème j'ai mis des chaînes sur une
voiture et en particulier mon métier
c'est d'être pilote alors comme je suis
bloqué au sol
voilà donc j'en profite il fallait être
prudent donc on a travaillé beaucoup
plus lentement et mais comme j'ai dit si
glissant dangereux donc il fallait
vraiment faire attention et on n'a pas
travaillé forcément avec le même rythme
que pendant la semaine à la maison
à la maison on marchait avec le chien
promener voilà personne forte en voiture
c'est très bien et toujours à propos de
ces conditions climatiques de la neige
qui tombe depuis plusieurs jours sur le
département des yvelines nous avons
ligne frédéric alphand du conseil
général bonsoir à vous vous êtes
directeur adjoint en charge des routes
dans le département des yvelines il est
18h15 pour ceux qui nous suivent en
direct sur tv fils quelle est la
situation à l'heure actuelle sur les
routes du département est ce que vous
avez une attention particulière sur
certains secteurs des mines alors à ce
stade toutes les routes sont comme on
dit en noir c'est à dire qu'elles ont
toutes été traités de la neige est
tombée dans l'après libye mais elle n'a
pas vraiment tenu que sur certaines
routes au sud des yvelines mais les
équipes sont intervenues elles vont
travailler et à l'heure où je vous parle
donc il faut confirme que toutes les
routes fontonnois il ya un dispositif
spécifique qui a été mis en place par le
conseil général pour cette période
jusqu'à 22 heures c'est la fin de la
vigilance orange dans le département
selon la préfecture
ces mises en place en fait pendant toute
la période hivernale du 15 novembre au
15 mars
on a des études qui sont d'astreinte en
permanence donc 24 heures sur 24 est
prête à intervenir en cas d'épisode
neigeux pour aller salle et racler les
geeks
là encore ce soir et ce que nous des
interventions sont prévues dans la nuit
de lundi à mardi
alors ce soir effectivement des
interventions de fer préventifs sont
prévus donc celle là je présente les
faits on va fall et les routes
l'événement
comment fonctionne ce dispositif vous
êtes en relation avec les services de
météo france avec les services de la
préfecture qui vous alerte alors pour
mais effectivement abonnés à faire ville
de météo france
un site internet est par ailleurs en cas
de nécessité
on appelle directement de trait du
violoniste à la station météo de trappes
donc nous donner les infos traître et il
est donc en fonction que les infos nos
patrouilleurs vont vérifier sur le
terrain l'état des routes est en
fonction depuis comptable et déclencher
l'intervention et vous nous dites ce
soir toutes les routes ont été salées
les conditions de circulation devraient
donc être bonne pour les automobilistes
en ce moment les conditions sont bonnes
c'est à dire qu'on est qu'on appelle à
un niveau c1 c'est à dire toutes les
routes l'eau noire merci frédéric halfon
du conseil général des yvelines
directeur adjoint du service route
département mobilisés afin de fluidifier
la circulation donc pour les
automobilistes nous reviendrons sur les
conséquences de la neige un peu plus
tard au cours de cette édition pour le
moment politique en ce mois de janvier
le point régulièrement dans le 7 8 sur
les cérémonies de voeux des responsables
politiques sur le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines et ce lundi le point
sur la cérémonie de voeux du maire de la
verrière